[Music]
I have the honor of hosting the red
carpet for the critics choice awards and
it could be a really big night for the
folks from lala land the musical
received 12 nominations and last night
at the premiere Carly steel took Emma
Stone and Ryan Gosling back to their
musical roots you started your career
singing and dancing and now here you are
in this incredible role nominated for it
what was it what was your fondest memory
of your early days I'm singing and
dancing my uncle was an Elvis
impersonator and I was in his act when I
was eight that was uh that was fun I'm
doing Mickey Mouse Club singing dancing
yeah that was really good training 90s
hip-hop is a little different from soft
shoe and all the other stuff that they
asked us to do here so I thought that
maybe some of that might help but it
really didn't know it was like starting
all over again
[Music]
in the musical movie which is already
getting Oscar buzz Ryan plays a jazz
musician who falls for an aspiring
actress played by Emma at last night's
premiere the 28 year old dazzled in a
share blue Prada midi with jewel detail
telling us she has her own early history
of seeing in the spotlight here comes
Emily style including a stint at 15
where she competed to be on a partridge
family remake just got to sing a couple
thongs on that but I feel like I really
learned when I was growing up yeah it
was a really wonderful experience
[Music]